mattei dans l'oreillette on est avec
cogeco et qu'il faut aller voir en
spectacle un je vous dis qu i qui sera
d'ailleurs pour sa dernière
représentation 100% libre le 28 avril
lors de son anniversaire ce sera folies
bergères que je serai je passerai le
voir et si tu veux que je fasse
n'importe quoi je le ferai pour toi
il y a laurent baffie dans ton oreille
sébastien choristes et les sabres avant
projet d'église 0 sur l'as tu vas devoir
répondre tout ce que tu dis laurent
baffie d'accord signé des questions très
simples signé mois sur les règles du jeu
oui je dois répéter ce qu'il dit mais ce
que je dois faire
oui aussi oui oui c'est quoi tous qui
dit jeff toms tu te dis quoi non bien
c'est le renard pardon à ses laurent
bien doit donc tu es ma grand mère je ne
mettrai pas un doigt dans les fesses de
magloire
non
voilà voilà
allez bon qu est question toi qui a été
l'assistant d' arthur l'animateur
jeunesse la plus grande qualité
il te déteste il te déteste il souhaite
notamment chaque jour il souhaite
d'abord chaque jour tu sais bien que je
t'aime c'est que la télévision à la plus
grande qualité dark met l'argent
l'argent
l'animateur télé que tu détestes jean
luc reichmann
c'est une tâche des citadis citadis est
une tâche mais je ne peux pas c'est
drôle jean luc et le premier a rigolé
tout comme en date dans le nord on
propose 20 euros à sa soeur bas parra
propose 20 euros à sa soeur quoi
[Applaudissements]
parmi ses dernières toiles képi car tu
aimes les femmes tri gide toi qui es
tunisien thèmes complexes la boulette
franchement c'est bien ça qu'est ce qui
t'a donné envie de faire de la télé ah
bon quand j'avais tourné vous est ce que
gagne un arthur je me suis dit je peux
le faire quand j'ai vu ton niveau et que
j'ai vu ce que gagne et arthur je me
suis dit je peux le faire ça me fait
beaucoup de peine que tu critiques
arthur déjà ça me dégoûte que tu me
mettre dans le même sac encore plus avec
quelle femme
regrettes-tu d'avoir une rue une
aventure d'un partenaire tu veux dire
j'en étais servent à les bons mais ça te
fait rire sa voix le sied pas tu as
monaco quand même mais dit le maire
d'oka merci pour tenir les chiens que
mains se balader en tout cas merci pour
ta mère les moins chers que ma soeur
mais bon
elle est bonne on voit ces passeurs bah
merci laurent bataille et merci qu'on
est attendu ce pôle